hey what's up guys my name is China
welcome back to my gamers in series so
last time we talked about creating a
separate sandbox 2d layer check out that
video if you haven't already and the
purpose for that was basically just to
prepare ourselves for doing 3d rendering
I want to get hazel into a state where
it will be as clean and as simple as
possible for us to just jam in 3d
rendering and be able to test everything
that we need to test as a result of
implementing that so in other words when
you start working on a new feature in
some kind of code base it's really good
to try and create some kind of test
environment for that so that you're able
to cleanly and easily kind of see if
what you've done actually works or not
especially when we're dealing with
something like C++ and we need to watch
out for memory leaks and any kind of
other like little things that you
wouldn't have to necessarily do in other
languages I think that it's important to
create as clean of an environment as
possible and the thing with that as well
is that because I guess you know we kind
of have hazel at a spot here where it is
relatively clean and simple and I think
there are too many bugs at all most of
you guys have fixed that using pull
requests which is fantastic but there
are still more things we can do right
and for those of you watching who really
want to contribute I'm not necessarily
contribute but also kind of learn I
guess and take hey we'll actually make
it a little bit your own and not just
copy everything I'm doing here or on
github but actually kind of implement
this into your own engine there are so
many more things you could do before you
start with your rendering one thing that
comes to mind immediately pretty much is
like profiling and like memory tracking
right so we're not doing anything like
that I have no idea if there's memory
but in hazel or not I can look at visual
studios diagnostic tools so I can see
hazel is running over here and in the
background I can kind of check out the
diagnostic tools in Visual Studio gives
you know consider this using about 100
mega Meg's of memory and that's not all
80 max of memory and that's not kind of
increasing like at all in fact it's kind
of decreased a bit so there's clearly
like no evident memory like or at least
not not a big one so there are tools the
visual studio provides and like
profiling you can do in visual studio as
well but that stuff is not stuff that I
would necessarily rely on they're not
because it's bad but because visual
studio is not gonna be the target
environment for ever
right when hazel eventually supports Mac
and Linux when hazel eventually might
support Android iOS that kind of stuff
what you want is in Engine Tools to do
things like that so for example I want
to see what the memory usage and hazel
is like and specifically Hales
Hazel's memory usage right it says all
this overhead from the runtime library
that all the runtime I guess this
Eastern and runtime that kind of stuff
where we kind of create a Windows
application to do all this stuff you
know there's all this kind of overhead
that you don't really see but
specifically from hazel for example you
know like I've created vertex arrays but
you know all this kind of you know I've
got my own sandbox 2d layer I want to
know how much memory I've used up in
actual hazel client space that kind of
stuff is important all right I've seen
graphs over time adding something like
that is really important and one of the
ways that you would do that is by
actually taking memory allocation into
your own hands so in other words
basically especially in debug mode
passing all memory allocations through
your own code so that you can actually
both record metrics on those memory
allocations but also in the future make
smarter decisions as to where the memory
comes from so that you're not hitting
the heap all the time so that's one
exercise that you guys could do if
you're interested in looking to custom
memory allocation but specifically
metrics and tracking and with profiling
as well right so some kind of timing
mechanism that will basically maybe by
instrumentation where you can maybe add
like a macro to each function or
something like that and it will track
how much time was spent inside that
function being able to then visualize
that data somehow super important and
that's actually something that will add
eventually whilst adding the 2d renderer
because what we're gonna do initially is
we're gonna implement a naive kind of 2d
renderer or something that works but
it's pretty basic and it's not gonna be
terrible but it's just not gonna be the
optimal solution it's gonna be a lot
more simple though so we'll do that
first and then as soon as we do that you
know will record metrics from from it
we'll see how fast it runs how many
sprites were able to render you know
will that text just about stuff we might
even do font rendering or something like
that although I think that will come
later and then after we have that set up
we're gonna look at an optimized kind of
2d bat renderer and how much of a
performance difference that makes that
you guys can really see that and of
course to do that I'm gonna have to add
some kind of profiling which I want to
add like custom profile
into his letter want to use physical
strategist profiling tools for that
specific example anyway that's kind of
the roadmap of what's gonna happen but
if you want to jump ahead if you want
something to do right now between these
weekly episodes then check out my memory
allocation metrics and then check out
some kind of profiling and I have a
video called timing in C++ which also
will benchmarking in C++ I think of
probably both that will actually show
you how to potentially write a little
benchmark anything but I've got a much
more advanced plan of course for this
game engine series anyway before I
continue just want to thank I was going
to say our sponsors for this video which
actually are all of you guys all of you
lovely patrons patreon conference after
show know is the best way to help
support this series and everything that
I'm doing here on YouTube huge thank you
as always I released an exclusive video
I think yesterday will based on what I'm
recording this video I really say
exclusive video yes today I'm gonna try
and do exclusive videos a lot more so
they three dollars a month to get into
that by the way and I'm trying to do one
awake starting from like now we'll see
how that goes there no guarantees of
course I'm just gonna try my best with
all those work that I have to do here
but ultimately you'll also get access to
the hazel development branch which is
like a lot more advanced version of this
and basically has like full 3d
renderings for if you're into 3d you're
into that kind of stuff you don't want
to deal with this 2d stuff which I mean
it's still important and still really
useful obviously we'll have to have that
anyway then you can jump ahead and help
support the series as well ok let's just
dive in I don't want to talk too much
the plan is gonna be pretty simple we're
gonna create a 2d renderer so it's gonna
be like a render a 2d class is gonna be
fully static we're gonna have a go up
reading more static approach to this
because I think we have a renderer but
it has some honor and storage somewhere
I'm not sure about that renderer is in
general should be static I might go over
I I what I want to do in general is
create very generic non game engine
story specific videos on hazel specific
videos the kind of detail you know water
to your enra is how to implement like a
batch render or how to do this how to do
that you know font rendering will
probably be its own standalone video so
that you guys can see how this works
outside of hazel because as the more we
build up is hope this code base the more
it's gonna be super specific to hazel
and that's not good for me
because you know the videos going to get
less views basically but also that's not
good for people trying to implement this
in their own engine base because having
all this hazel code around it
complicates things because we'll start
relying on like layers and you know our
own kind of library of code essentially
whereas if someone wants to kind of take
that and implement it in their own
engine that's gonna be really difficult
so we'll kind of end up having both will
kind of end up probably having a pretty
lightly explained implementation in
hazel but then also an in-depth kind of
maybe OpenGL stories video just a
standalone kind of video that will cover
the architecture and how to implement
something from scratch in a Santaland
video so that's kind of my plan with
these things as we start getting into
more complicated matters and as I
mentioned we probably like for now I'm
just gonna write all the code to your
end present although not that difficult
to implement so I'm still gonna write
all of the card in front of you guys but
in the future we may need to switch to
like diffs or just alike already written
code or something like that because the
just the volume of code is gonna grow
and grow and grow and that's gonna be
unsustainable anyway let's jump in and
take a look at the 2d renderer okay so
this is the sandbox 2d class that I was
talking about this is what we've made it
so far it's pretty simple and that was
kind of the point to keep it as bad as
possible there are a few things that I
still want to fix up but we'll kind of
do that as we go specifically this
upload uniform float for and just in
general when we start uploading matrices
as well we're casting that dynamically
toward OpenGL shader I think that what I
might do is just have a set map for or
setback for set float for whatever
something like that in the base shadow
class for now because my hopes was that
we were going to implement a material
system soon and use like uniform buffers
essentially and in that case we actually
wouldn't need to upload individual
variables but because I think that is
still far off and also I think that's a
good feature to have for debugging right
for example I just want to quickly set a
uniform flow for a map for or something
in the shader without going through
material system without going through
the revaruraa it's probably good idea to
have that so that's kind of a - dude I'm
all totally this is a tutor you know
data set map for and
but oh my gosh ADA set floats all right
so these are two functions that I want
to add so add these functions okay so I
kind of want to add these two functions
so that we don't have to do the dialing
cost and those we kind of fixes that
which will kind of look a lot better we
won't have to include movie al-shater
either which kind of ties everything to
OpenGL of course because this includes
some simplest shader which includes
actually no this doesn't of course the
visual studio keeps crashing I need to
really fix everything last time as well
I'm not sure what's going on in and have
any extensions installed anyway whatever
the show must go on as they say so next
time I'll have like a different computer
may be running this so what we'll do is
we'll take a look at we kind of have
this in general we have a renderer begin
saying let's take a look at that because
that's our initial thing we have seen
data here which is a static kind of seem
data kind of stuff which is fine that's
what we have here that's fantastic
that's kind of the same idea that will
take and implement in a renderer 2d
let's go ahead and just start writing
the code so inside renderer and I'll
make sure that I'm in sharable files
mark because if I'm not it's going to be
disaster yep I am I'll add a new item
I'll create a CPP file called render a
2d dot CPP and I will do the same thing
for our let's see here for our H file so
this will be namespace hazal
and then we'll have a class renderer 2d
now this is gonna be super static super
static is something that I just made up
on the spot
but basically what super stack means is
this has zero storage this does not deal
with storage at all this is gonna be a
storage less class there's not gonna be
any private like static stuff here at
all it's gonna just be a set of render
commands that's kind of what you want to
have or at least what I want to have in
this case we're gonna have to go doing
it this way I'm gonna see what that ends
up look
so we'll have static void you know to
begin scene we know that that's kind of
taken an orthographic camera we know
it's not going to modify that'll do that
over traffic camera so I'll just take it
in as a reference so we'll say also drop
the camera camera and we'll have to
include that all the traffic camera so
begin saying we've got we'll have a
static boy dancing which I don't imagine
we'll do pretty much anything in a
simple render scenario in a batch render
it will probably upload the vertex data
to the GPU but for a simple kind of
primitive renderer like this I don't
think it will do anything like that at
all and then we'll have our actual you
know primitive will say primitives so
this kind of system stuff begin the same
an same we probably want to have a nice
and shut down as well
again it is fully statics or we
definitely need to basically have what
the equivalent of constructor and
destructor will be now that there's this
huge there's this huge question that I
get asked very very often which is why
why static why have a renderer be static
and you don't have to have a renderer be
static this is not something that's like
you know your renders are gonna work on
as a static the whole concept of static
and object and instantiation and
object-oriented programming and all of
this stuff that is all a language
construct what matters in the end are
the actual OpenGL calls and data
transformation data management stuff
that you're actually doing inside
functions if you think about if you go
back to the root level and you think
about what object are in T programming
is you know what is a class what is a
member function it's just a static
function with a pointer to a block of
data that's what it is that's what
that's what classes are that's how they
work so ultimately by making something
static all you're doing is saying that
I'm not going to have a separate block
of data for each class right for each
instance of my render a 2d class that I
need to point to every time you're
saying that I will manage that block of
data myself that's what you're doing
which is a different way to think about
it of course because that's not
typically that's not typically the way
that you would think about it if you're
just learning on your own
you're just thinking about you know you
know everything has to be a class
everything has to be that with that
right but it's true um and I think that
as you kind of probably get more into as
you become a better engineer I'll say
and obviously I don't know what level
you guys are outside but you know if you
pass this level I'm not gonna this is
gonna be a waste of time for you but for
those of you who are still kind of
getting into software engineering maybe
or don't have that much experience or
wrapping your head around programming
and C++ and how that all works you know
in the end obviously all we're doing is
we're executing CPU instructions all of
these constructs that we see here like
classes they help us organize our code a
little a little bit better and make
things certain things easier right
because they take some of the management
stuff away from us and essentially
converted into syntax sugar that's what
they're doing all right but at the end
of the day what are we doing in the 2d
renderer we're executing an OpenGL
commands right not necessarily all we're
doing I mean you know we have to do some
kind of potentially some kind of maths
as well but ultimately what are we doing
we're managing some kind of data set
which is our scene essentially right and
then we're executing OpenGL commands
we're taking an input data such as I
want a rectangle here on the screen and
then we're basically just saying that
you know given this rectangle that
you've given me with this data I'm going
to you know upload this uniform matrix
to the shader
and then execute a drop call that's what
we're doing right that in Norway
involves classes or anything like that
that is just opengl functions that were
calling with data now why is this in a
class in the first place mainly because
it's gonna look better from an API point
of view right if it's not a static class
if it is like because this kutis might
as well be a namespace by the way we
could make a namespace called render 2d
I've made it a class for no other reason
just because that's it's just gonna look
nicer you know there's no actual
difference it's gonna look nicer it's
gonna be a recognizable type you know
there's not going to be any instances of
it because it's all completely static
but ultimately and I don't want to get
too much into this and confuse you guys
too much but basically what I'm saying
is that a render 2d is something that's
global it's a wrapper over certain GPU
render commands that's what it is right
the data
that it has to have is is a singleton in
the sense that like you only have one
active scene at once
you only have one render to date at once
you cannot have you know multiple copies
of render activity what does that even
mean your friend or a 2d doesn't contain
any data itself what is what is another
instance of retro sweetie it's nothing
right it's just an instance of render 2d
would just be a a vehicle yeah I would
say I don't know anyone who I'm talking
about right now to be honest but I hear
it would be like a method I guess of
calling a function which is going to
execute OpenGL commands which can be
arbitrary anyway because they're not you
know they're not tied to a specific
OpenGL instance OpenGL inherently is
something that's global alright so it
makes sense to make a static renderer
because first of all you know the
renderer is sequential there is no such
thing as I'm gonna begin a scene with
one render and then bigger scene with my
other end or instance that's that's not
done right you do everything
sequentially kind of consecutively right
chronologically you could say as well
you do everything line by line you begin
your scene you submit your print
primitives you end your scene you can do
this anywhere in your entire code base
it doesn't matter but ultimately that's
the flow of the renderer that's how it
works okay so hopefully that little
explanation that makes sense completely
unplanned I was just gonna write the
code but then I started thinking about
you know other other like messages that
people have written me and and stuff
like that that ultimately what we're
dealing with here is you know dumb it
down dumb it down to what you're
actually doing OpenGL wires here and
then you'll realize that you know
ultimately I need some kind of data
store potentially because I need to know
what the active scene is maybe right I
need to have like a specific shader
potentially it was bound right but
ultimately what this is is an incredibly
kind of static kind of procedurally
programmed you know a piece of code that
just says that I activate my scene I do
all of my necessary stuff and then I do
a bunch of like OpenGL commands or
potentially store things in some kind of
buffer if I need to for more advanced
renderer and then I just you know
execute a draw cold that's what I'm
doing it's super simple there's no need
to complicate it and it
definitely no need to instantiate a
class like this whatsoever okay so for
the first thing that I want to do here
is basically have a function that lets
me draw a quad so I want to say draw
part now I could call it fill quad
because it's gonna be filled in but I'm
not gonna really do anything like that
what it's gonna have draw quad what do
you think about what we actually want to
take in here as far as parameters go so
I'm gonna be probably suggesting that we
have a vector two which is our position
normally you were I mean ultimately you
probably want to deal with both back to
a new vector3 the reason is we can use
that third zet coordinate for kind of
sorting essentially in the z axis so
it's kind of like a z-index type thing
where you can basically be like again
rendering this last but I want it to be
like at the very back of my scene so
I'll set it to have like a position of
negative 0.5 in the z axis by doing
something like this you can kind of
create layering right and you can
basically control yeah you can basically
create your own layers in terms of like
you know I'll have a layer 0.9 point
eight point seven point six negative
axis right and then zero will kind of be
the center of my scene and then if I
want things explicitly in front I can
render them and like I said of 0.5 right
or something like that or you know the
other way around you know because I
think the way that our projection is set
up at the moment is that negative values
go towards the camera right whereas
positive z values go away from the
camera so I'll leave it as vector
position for now we probably want some
kind of size as well typically when you
render something like this this can be a
vector this will be sized
and then I also want to have a vet for
which basically says what our color is
and again as I mentioned it's nice to
have a vector E instead of a vector so
I'll Pat this as well this is the
skeleton for our 2d renderer here so
I'll include our PCH I'll include our
render or a true team a file here in
main space nasal and now what's going to
use a little sis but I don't have that
it's told so we'll just implement
everything manually let me see if I can
just do that and then add a bunch of
jelly brackets everywhere I could have
used Visual Studio
implement the functions actually no I
think about it but as I care this is not
going to take it too long and then the
last thing that I need of course is that
render a 2d namespace okay cool so now
we have everything so one of the first
things that we need to do for the
renderer we're gonna try and blaze
through this as fast as possible because
the videos already like 20 miles long
but basically what I want to do is the
same way that we create we begin a scene
here and we get a cameraman we do all of
this stuff right this is going to become
hazel render a 2d begin scene I'll add
this to Hazel dot age as well and I
can't use your sister from the file
stuff to do this so we have renderer
I'll also have a render HUD all right so
that we have access to this and so now
we have a hazel render a 2d begin scene
which is great and then again to the
hazel render a 2d and seen will have as
well not nothing like submitting here
there needs to be none this stuff is
well gone you know we'll keep this
around just for a bit because we all
probably need to copy it but ultimately
it doesn't need to exist set clay color
clear that stuff will probably move to
the renderer eventually as well and then
the really our test here would be
something like we had submit with a
particular square which I wish I didn't
remove so let's see we just okay well it
was just yeah okay we do it with like a
scale or whatever and with the color so
we'll just say draw quad and then we'll
take in a position I'll just keep it as
0 a size maybe of you know 1 1 or
something like that and then a color
which all set to let's make this like
red maybe a bit kind of on the red side
here with a number of one ok so we have
a draw quad here
now that should draw a 1 by 1 quad
that's kind of what we would expect
right so let's go ahead and convert all
of this stuff into basically something
that we can use in our to your Andhra so
the way this is gonna work is I'm going
to cut this card here I'm gonna pop it
into around routine into your nest and
then now you II bet you know you realize
that hang on a minute
we need state right we need to have some
kind of storage for this but this is
super easy to do and again does not
require any kind of state
instances what we do here is again we
just have something like renderer to the
storage right or something like that it
ultimately doesn't even matter at all
and you can kind of format this however
you like we'll do something like this to
begin with
and then you just have all the stuff
that you need so for example red vertex
array
you know this becomes our you know I'll
say our vertex array and then we have
and this may need to like include some
things here red vertex array for example
I don't know if I can actually call it
that is the same as a type but we'll
kind of leave it like that for now maybe
so better array and then you know we
don't need a better spot or anything
like that what else we need a shader so
you know it will cut out black color
shader helpful is quadrats x-ray and
then shader as well will include right
and then what we do is we just take
around ro 2 D we make this static so
that it's kind of so there's like unique
I guess to this translation unit
specifically um so there's not
completely global for linkage purposes
and then we'll just call this what
should I call this render up probably
just data
how many can call this daughter as well
but I just called a storage because I
guess that's what it is anyway so we
have this right it's super simple we
have as data and then any time we want
something we just access it so we just
say s data dot and you can make this a
pointer I've made it just a normal kind
of it's got a bunch F when I've just
made it kind of a normal a normal kind
of stack based kind of function it is
static though so it's gonna exist with
lifetime the whole application sorry
because it doesn't really matter about
initializing or like the initializing
this at all you know this doesn't run
code upon an initialization that needs
to be done at a certain point it's just
going to default initialize a bunch of
shared pointers which is obviously
trivial and not something we have to
worry about so we kind of keep it as
that if you start growing this and you
have like for example of static array
which has like a bunch of elements
elements I know I don't know you might
have stuff here that actually uses up
considerable storage and you want to
manage that at that point you can make
this a pointer and then allocate it in a
specific allocator
or an arena or some
like that but for now we're not gonna
worry about that at all so quadrat x-ray
becomes this and then you know it's same
with here and here and then flat college
head of course would just be s da da da
flat color shadow okay so now we're kind
of doing something that's a little bit
better I guess
this okay cool we're actually okay
that's fine
just looking at these vertices they look
fine to me as well the position will be
probably modified using just a matrix in
this case but that looks pretty good to
me I'm just coming through it all we
have is position which is probably fine
and that's what we all we need for this
simple renderer okay let's just see if
we can get this to work so everything
else I'll kind of leave as it is another
reason to have an end shutdown by the
way is because you can that way you can
explicitly like control the memory
because at this point you know this is
this stuff is not gonna get deleted or
released until we actually shut it down
manually so it might actually be worth
kind of making this some kind of point
or essentially and then explicitly
controlling the memory in fact I think I
will do that because I just see problems
being caused in the future so this is
really simple again what you do is you
take this and you just initialize it
here a lot of these parenthesis even
though you don't have to we'll take this
now becomes an arrow so just to be clear
the reason that I don't want to leave it
as a kind of automatically managed piece
of memory is because in shutdown I
specifically want to delete this the
reason is that shut down here will for
example destroyed vertex arrays right
and it's important that this stuff
happens because if you look at the
constructor for and where is this I have
to use this unfortunately but anyway if
you use if you look at the destructor
for and I've been jailed vertex array
right it will actually called you a
colon up and gel function which relates
it from the GPU
if this gets shut down as a result of
this you know if this gets shut down if
we look at the renderer this thing the
renderer has to get shut down and while
we still have an OpenGL context
otherwise that code is just not gonna
run it's gonna crash so because of that
we need to explicitly actually call
those disruptors which is what do
will do delete will delete this the
reference will get released hopefully
nothing else is holding on to it
obviously and in fact this could again
just be roll pointers for that purpose
as well they definitely don't need to be
wraps they could be scopes in fact that
probably would be better just because
you know that I'm going to get passed
around anywhere it's important to think
about lifetime for reasons like this I
think I will make this a scope the only
problem is that we don't really support
scope this becomes a huge kind of issue
that we will probably end up talking
about later because of the way the API
is structured but ultimately my point is
that we need to explicitly control the
lifetime of this and delete it
explicitly like manually by ourselves
not just wait a lifetime of the program
to delete them which is what would
happen with half this being a pointer
because there is certain OpenGL code
that needs to run and obviously we need
to guarantee that that happens before
the OpenGL context gets released anyway
all the hazal namespaces here can just
get deleted in fact I think I'll just
kind of look at the current selection
here selection and just replace that
with nothing okay cool so there we have
it brilliant okay so that aside begins
scene will simply upload the camera data
as it kind of does before so if we look
over here and we see this kind of well
what the other renderer did I guess if
we look at renderer and then look at the
B key in the same function you know it's
at the view projection matrix and then
that that was set dynamically for kind
of each shader if we look at our actual
shader that we're dealing with which is
our flat color shader let's take a look
at what the student has the cases God
view projection has got a transform
great so if we go to let's see if we go
to back to sandbox and we look at for
example this will copy this line of code
and then back in render a 2d and begin
scene what we'll do because the shaders
can get bound once writers will bind the
shader which is what we're doing here on
this will just be s data and then flat
color data we could just call this
shader honestly just because it is like
that simple but leave like this now
we look at what we have before I think
we need platform urban gel shadow so and
I go back here and again that is on the
to-do list to be removed and then
dynamic point a cost okay this one in
all right so we buy the shader and then
what I want to do is of course set a or
upload uniform match for and then this
will actually be so you do projection
projection and then this will be the
actual matrix and the matrix being
camera gets purchased give you
projection matrix okay so we end up with
something like that and then end scene
in this case doesn't nothing and then
draw quad at a particular position all
that stuff basically what we'll do is
what do we have before it doesn't really
matter I think it's got the color as
well so let's take this now if we set
uniforms here ultimately it kind of is
important to make sure that shader is
bound so what you would do is you were
trying to bind it again in almost in in
in the future what will do is this will
actually look at what the currently back
down shader is and then not call that
function again if it hasn't changed the
problem is that theoretically you could
begin a scene and then do something in
3d land which would then rebind the
shader this shouldn't happen but it
might so it's safer to just leave a bind
there just before you do anything but
ultimately again because that binder can
be expensive because it's not gonna be L
call you could catch that essentially
and just make sure that if it's still if
the shader that you bound here is still
bound then just basically ignore this
call and that's also commonly done okay
so upload this will be uploading from
float for this will be you color and
then will upload the color here and then
to do to do the actual draw pole what we
should do is basically what we did I
think in renderer which was just that
x-ray vibe and then run a command for
indexed so back in here will do this and
again you can see this is kind of the
naive
naive kind of implementation I guess
well we're actually just taking the
Plymouth right we're actually just
immediate my kind of rendering
everything but that's kind of step one I
guess into getting the stuff to work so
let's see what do I need I need the
render command thing which I think is
just running eh
yep okay cool so there we go render
command draw index and then it should be
Pequod vertex right I'm not sure if we
need to bind it though I guess we do
draw index to vertex array okay yeah
sure so we still have to bind it which
is fine and then we'll just do draw
index which is fine okay great so we
should get a quad riding from this right
it should be pretty simple again I've
seen has nothing I'll copy this this is
the vector position I'll copy just put
it here because really what should
happen is this should call draw quad
except the difference will be that will
kind of do a position the x position Y
and then zero for that for that and then
size color just gets folded like that so
basically defaulting that to be zero if
you specify a vector that corner will be
zero and it will just flow through the
same card obviously that looks pretty
good to me so of course for ignoring
position size that's something that
we'll tackle in the next episode that
looks pretty good to me we should try
this out I guess let's just have five
and well we'll see what happens okay so
straight away of course we get an error
and begin scene that's to be expected
because of cause I didn't call a knit or
shutdown anywhere so if we kind of go
back here what I should do is inside
application this should be maybe down in
the three in around row if we look at
application and what application does
let's take a look here so sandbox where
is application application or syrupy you
can see what that does is it initializes
the renderer and what the renderer
should do is also and once the verona
arena commander meet such as initializes
the api sure what this should do is
actually call render a 2d in it right so
that way when we initialize the three
because this is kind of like the main
renderer um it will also kind of spin
off and initialize the 2d renderer so
render a 2d age and then we don't have a
shutdown yet which we definitely need to
have but when we do have a shutdown
we'll kind of stick that in there okay
let's hit f5 and see what happens okay
so we get a blank screen with absolutely
no square so let's debug that and see
won't work wrong specifically I think
what I want to do is check out the
shader because if you've got a pretty
sure everything else is correct so we
are doing well we are multiplying this
by transform which kind of implies that
the transform needs to be set up
otherwise it won't work
so what I'll do because if that's coming
in as 0 then our matrices all up that
position is not being output correctly
at all so back in renderer to do CDP
what I'll do is apart from just
uploading the view projection I'll also
upload the transform except the
transform I will just set gtlm matte for
one point zero F for now let's see if
that makes any difference ok and there
we have our square which is now you know
the camera you can see still works
everything looks pretty good to me but
now we have of course the square which
the square color doesn't affect anything
because we passed in a constant of red
but I think we'll kind of leave it as
that okay cool so hope you guys enjoyed
this video is very simple look at the
beginnings of our 2d renderer next time
what we'll do is actually make it so
that we can control the position and the
size and so that we can render multiple
in at the at the moment we can
definitely random multiple squares but
they'll all be at the same position at
the same size but the color will be
variable so we'll take a look at how we
can set the transform as well to be what
it needs to be in the next episode I do
want to stress that this is a very
simple approach to to your rendering of
course we are gonna expand on this and
make it a lot better than it is right
now but I think it's fun of course to
begin at the beginning and show you guys
what a simple 2d renderer looks like and
the concepts behind that before we do
actually expand and make something a
little bit better you guys did enjoy
this video please hit that like button
don't forget to help support the series
on patron accomplish at the churner and
I will see you guys in the next video
goodbye
[Music]